a general strike nationwide protests um
turning violent but all aimed at the
government of Jer bosun ro swept across
Brazil
the last to take place in Rio where
thousands gathered to march on the
city's main train station the arrival of
so-called black bloc anarchists in the
midst of more mainstream demonstrators
all but guaranteed violence here
[Music]
at the end of the demo route they drew
together shooting firecrackers at the
police
let's go behind me
[Applause]
and so it started
and tear gas and blast bombs scattering
the crowds
police flanking the protesters fired
from all sides from the centre riot
police push forwards in close formation
both be fired
since incoming us fireworks as well
riot police are moving in thickness has
got to go on for quite a while now
they're looking for troublemakers in
different alleyways big explosions
they're coming from the left side
they're running from over here
we are the police right behind us now in
the chaos a mother and daughter were
engulfed by tear gas people rushed
forward to help them spraying water into
the girls eyes to suit
despite the risks of injury protestors
insist there would be more
demonstrations against the president
[Music]
from the skies police helicopters
monitored the protesters as the March
was slowly but surely dismantled on the
ground this was the president's first
general strike since taking office in
January he'll likely face many more
Sturm G Sky News Rio de Janeiro